it's graduation for these young students
at Taipei University but while there are
thoughts maybe on their careers their
hearts are with fellow students in Hong
Kong a quick glance around the cafeteria
makes it clear where their sympathies
lie and who their common enemy is China
in the past
China's interference was not so
noticeable but now it is if we allow
this to continue it would be like the
frog in the slowly boiling water it
doesn't notice the heat until it dies
the current political movement Taiwan is
really unpleasant tensions are growing
red paint attacks on activists critical
of China hooliganism and vandalism and
solidarity demonstrations for Hong Kong
foreign journalists have been verbally
abused by / China advocates like mrs.
Zhang here member of a China Patriots
association the group's headquarters are
here in Taiwan's capital Taipei a
Chinese flag flies over the building
inside a portrait of Taiwan's former
president Chiang kai-shek hangs
alongside current Chinese President Xi
Jinping China born mrs. Zhang is busy
painting patriotic slogans this one
reads for unification with China against
Taiwan's independence that's a way home
yes Chinese in Taiwan his sons and
daughters of the Chinese nation we're
taking on the responsibility of pushing
for the unification of our country
then they plaster their campaign bus in
slogans they want to give taiwan's
liberal pro-independence president a
piece of their mind taiwan's authorities
strongly suspect that the CPA gets
resources from China through back
channels but Taiwan has a powerful
opponent Pro China groups and media
organizations often financed by wealthy
businessmen and women are the most
obvious means of Chinese influence but
more subtle mischievous methods are
employed using social media the
politically independent Taiwan
fact-check Center in Taipei has been
monitoring the sharp increase in fake
news these include repeated claims often
using manipulated content that Taiwan
has been behind the protests in Hong
Kong
now since local elections at the end of
2018 we've become aware in Taiwan that
we have become victims of an information
war that China has been waging against
us in order to manipulate Taiwanese
society and elections those local
elections saw the meteoric rise of a man
that previously no one had heard of honk
will you from the opposition pro-china
Normand dong party now a presidential
candidate a populace propelled by a
well-oiled political machine who's
especially gaining ground in social
media where did this sudden momentum
come from honey
claims China has nothing to do with it
[Applause]
but jung and her patriotic chinese
association who aged their fight for
independence out in the open at Taiwan's
presidential palace they proudly hand
over their petition in the petition were
calling for the president to recognize
that there is only one China and for a
peaceful unification with the mainland
they hope that in a not too distant
future
China's flag will eventually fly over
Taipei